yeah back at Dennis dude open the door
all right guys hang on a second it's
like a
11 o'clock in the morning here yeah open
the door surprise [__] okay if you're a
creep near London or Dublin listen up
tickets are officially on sale now for
our upcoming London and Dublin tour
that's right in case you missed the
announcement we're bringing the podcast
to London and Dublin and all four of us
will be performing live on April 16th at
Royal Albert Hall we've got two shows on
April 16th in London and we head to
Dublin for shows on the 17th and the
19th so go to the always sunnypod.com
and get your tickets now Glenn
definitely does not want to hear you
complain about not getting tickets and
if you are not there I swear by the gods
I will lose it